herzlich willkommen so salis welt heute
geht es wieder weiter bei uns im garten
und ich zeige euch heute unsere fleißige
jeder unserer meere butter und die
kümmert sich in zukunft um das
rasenmähen ich meine gartenarbeit macht
mir echt zu wirklich spaß aber
rasenmähen gehört nicht zu den
tätigkeiten die ich super gerne mache
oder um die ich mich jetzt reise das
gießen fällt ja bei uns im prinzip auch
weg denn wir haben ein smart system für
den garten
das steuert dann die bewässerung das
steuert und sagt mir bescheid wann ich
den boden wieder bringen muss und jetzt
habe ich wie gesagt auch der mähroboter
so dass ich mich einfach um andere dinge
im garten kümmern kann
die pflanzen zurechtschneiden obsternten
gemüse ernten oder mit die kräuterbeete
kümmern und werden uns jetzt hier für
den gardena sie leno live entschieden
und zwar muss man einfach gucken welche
garten größer man hat also wieviel
rasenfläche habe ich die gemäht werden
muss und der herr reich jetzt bis 750
quadratmeter kann man herrschern guck
mal das ist die frida die fleißige
frieda habe ich dir jetzt genannt ich
glaub es laut das erste was man macht
wenn man ein mähroboter hat man gibt ihm
einen namen
der buchautor der murat wäre auch cool
gewesen aber so heißt es schon der
papagei und das ist die fleißige frieda
weißt du was die man die nähte an
unseren rasen
die fete dann jeden tag und mäht den
rasen
nein das ist die fleißige fregatte ist
ganz ganz lieb zu uns die hilft und zum
garten hin zum einen haben uns eben
wegen der garten größer die gerade die
viele friedrich ist hast du grad der
friede einen kuss gegeben
auch die schau bis hin zum einen haben
wir uns für dieses gerät entschieden
der größe das heißt unser garten unsere
rasenfläche so groß und da reicht die
akkulaufzeit der ist wirklich super
leise vätern jeden tag raus und die
installation ist echt super einfach bei
uns liegt jetzt jedoch keine rollrasen
bewusst mich denn man kann hier dieses
system vorher verlegen aber man kann es
auch im nachhinein nach ist das geht
auch
[Musik]
wir haben für den silly no life
entschieden wegen frack datengröße damit
nämlich bis zu 750 quadratmeter rasen
auf einmal
außerdem mit der wirklich super leise
ist wetterunabhängig kann also bei jedem
wetter raus fahren
er ist wirklich super einfach
installiert und wir müssen nie mehr
rasenschnitt entsorgen also bei uns war
es früher so wir haben in einem
mehrfamilienhaus gewohnt in so einem
hochhaus und mein papa und mama die
haben die gärtner arbeit gemacht und bei
uns war es beim so wir haben jede woche
oder alle zwei wochen aber den rasen
gemäht der papa hat es so ein riesen
gerät ich weiß auch dabei um so ja wieso
eine schneide klinge einfach drin jahre
immer wieder nach schleifen lassen
müssen
man hat diesen riesen sack voll rasen
gehabt also dem schnitt und er hat halt
immer alles entsorgen müssen und bei
mehr robotern ist es so die fahren jeden
tag drauf als die jeden tag ihr stand
der rasen gleichmäßig gemäht und der
schnitt abfangen da wird einfach auf den
rasen zurück gelegt er bleibt da und
wirkt dann praktisch als dünger was ich
ziemlich cool findet denn wir haben dann
keinen müll
ich zeige mich jetzt einfach mal wie wir
den installieren wie gesagt könnt ihr
denn auch legen wenn ihr schon in rasen
habt das gar kein problem
wir legen sie es einfach drunter weil
sich bei uns anbietet das einzige was
man bei der installation berücksichtigen
muss man frauen natürlich strom im
garten das haben wir zugelegt und hier
ist auch die ladestation als ich hier
ist die frieda zu hause bei uns im
garten und später baum war da noch ein
häuschen drüber und dann kann sie immer
raus fahren zum mähen und wieder
zurückfahren und die installation ist
supereinfach die könnt ihr alleine
machen oder einfach als familien
beschäftigung lasst euch einfach vom
papa oder opa helfen der brauch mal was
zu tun
ich habe jetzt hier unterstützung von
papa von emilia und das ist doch eine
tochter und zwar hat sie gerade ferien
und darf hier mithelfen und rainhard er
hat ja schon den murat ganz fleißig
unterstützt und ich meine wir haben so
etwas noch nie gemacht werden um den
garten angelegt und auch wir hatten auch
noch keinen smart garten deswegen habe
ich da professionelle hilfe
hier gibt es eine schablone und zwar ist
ganz wichtig dass man beim abschluss
also werden überall diese steine gelegt
dass man beim abschluss immer zehn
zentimeter weg bleibt wenn der abschluss
bündig ist ich habe jetzt unseren oliv
baum den haben wir in so ein hochbeet
gepackt und da bleiben weiß 35cm weg und
dann haben wir so einen nagel
damit werden wir das begrenzungs kabel
einfach schön fixieren und dann weiß der
mähroboter also die fleißige frieda wo
sie überall wehen darf verstößt nirgends
an und haut nicht ab aus dem garten
[Musik]
hier bleiben wir jetzt nur zehn
zentimeter weg weil er die terrasse
bündig zum rasen sein wird und da keiner
der mähroboter einfach so ein bisschen
drüber fahren
das passt dann ich zeige euch mal die
unterseite von der frieda und zwar sind
hier unten diese drei klingen und die
drehen sich und medien praktisch den
rasen also wieso rasierklingen sind noch
ganz scharf und ich denke dass wir ihn
bei uns jeden tag laufen lassen und man
sagt dann ungefähr dass man so alle drei
monate neue klingen braucht aufs jahr
gerechnet sind dann vielleicht 20 euro
also diesen wirklich sehr günstig man
muss sie nicht nach schleifen lassen
wie bei einer rasierklinge tauscht man
einfach aus und man kann auch einstellen
wann der rasen gemäht werden soll
also früher durfte man ja sonntags
keinen rasen mähen weil es einfach
ziemlich laut war und ziemlich nervig
war ich weiß noch wie es bei uns war im
haus und bei diesen ist es aber im
prinzip gar kein problem weil er
wirklich sehr leise ist ich werde
trotzdem wahrscheinlich so machen das
war vormittags den rasen mähen lassen
wenn alle kinder in der schule und im
kindergarten sind und wenn die kids
nachmittags da sind sich die frieda hier
wieder in ihrem häuschen die kids können
auf dem rasen spielen
aber wie gesagt man kann es einfach
selber entscheiden
hier müssen jetzt einmal um den baum
herum denn wir haben jetzt hier die
rasenfläche mittendrin haben wir den
baum und der roboter muss es natürlich
auch erkennen hier genau media zeigt dir
wie und dann muss man einfach alle kabel
miteinander verbinden
als ich echt super einfach
[Musik]
dann stehen wir jetzt diese insel also
diesen baum und diese erde die wir jetzt
hier auf geschüttet haben
da weisheit nicht schlimm in der
mähroboter ein bisschen dran fährt das
heißt da bleiben wir es nur 20 cm
aber hier bei dem holz da müssen wir
natürlich wieder 30 weg bleiben damit
noch nicht an stößt also haben wir das
hier so geschafft und dann wird hier
vorne wieder verbunden
zur sparte an der mähroboter diese insel
hier aus fährt um den baum herum
und hier kommt das kabel dann wieder
schön zusammen und ganz dicht zusammen
und dann väter hier einfach wieder
drüber also lässt diese stelle dann
nicht aus so hebt sich das signal auf
und der mähroboter spart wirklich nur
das aus was ich aus gespart haben möchte
ich jetzt immer hier bereits am ende
einmal drumherum alle aussparungen
gemacht jetzt wird natürlich mit der
ladestation verbunden
hier habe ich jetzt such kabel also dass
der roboter auch wenn ich dafür und
seien häufiger findet das video
hineingedrückt und die begrenzungs kabel
verstecken wir hier unten beim
rasenkanten stein
[Musik]
da hört sich jetzt das kabel kommt hier
so eine klammer drum wird hier eingelegt
und zog gedrückt und dann wird es hier
angeschlossen und wären alles richtig
angeschlossen habt alles gut verbunden
habt dann leuchtet die diode hier grün
und jetzt muss ich im prinzip nur noch
die ladestation fixieren mit diesen er
nägel
das mache ich aber erst morgen wenn der
rasen liegt
heute wird endlich der rollrasen gelegt
ich bin jetzt hier in der küche noch ein
bisschen beschäftigt werde kochen und
backen und der murat decke wird sich
jetzt draußen den rollrasen und erklärt
euch warum wir wohl rasen haben wie man
ihn verlegt und was für tipps und tricks
gibt der backofen der dampfloks
recherche nach draußen hat warten so die
sally hat ja gestern schon den draht und
dem beginnt mit dem so auch die sally
hat ja gestern schon den begrenzungs rat
für den für den rasenmäher gemacht für
den automatischen rasenmäher und jetzt
brauchen natürlich rasen und ich muss
euch sagen rollrasen habe ich schon sehr
oft gelegt damals und zwar ein bisschen
schon zwei 3000 quadratmeter das ist
ganz ganz einfach ein rollrasen link und
ich bin auch ein absoluter fan von
rollrasen legen ein rollrasen hat
natürlich viele viele vorteile
ja ein ganz großer vorteil ist wenn man
den rasen neu anlegt haben wir zwei
möglichkeiten entweder man sät ihn ein
oder man den rollrasen an rollrasen
kostet am anfang wir sind ein bisschen
mehr geld ich glaube der
quadratmeterpreis beim rasen kommt immer
darauf an was von rasen man den blick
zwischen vier und sechs euro
und wir haben es von rollrasen
entschieden wäre es ziemlich schnell
geht und bei der ziemlich dicht
bewachsen ist das heißt wenn man sich in
rollrasen holt da kann man sich sicher
sein dass kein unkraut dazwischen nicht
dass keine pilze dazwischen sind und
deswegen uns von rollrasen entschieden
weil es auch ziemlich schnell geht
nachteilig wenn man sich einen rasen
seht das dauert zwar ziemlich dauert
wirklich lange und dann ist noch das
andere andere nachteilig wenn ihr da
diese keimlinge die samen legt für den
rasen dann brauchen sie ziemlich lange
bis sie anwachsen unkraut wächst
schneller und haben schnell mal unkraut
stellen wir euch darin ihren rasen
selber mit und deswegen haben uns von
rollrasen entschieden saumäßig einfach
zu machen was wir in den letzten zwei
tagen die jungs gemacht haben wir haben
hier alles plan eben gemacht könnt ihr
mal hier sehen alles planen eben gemacht
alles jetzt mit dem rechen bearbeitet
und jetzt tut mir gerade noch ein
bisschen an rechnen weil ungefähr einer
halben stunde mit der rollrasen kommen
dann nehme ich mit meinem felix und wenn
gm ein rollrasen abholen da zeigt auch
im euch mal wie so ein rollrasen
hergestellt wird wir haben natürlich
jetzt hier im vorteil wir hatten keine
rasenfläche hier
und wirklich ein ganz normalen sandigen
spargel boden und wie gesagt einen plan
eben gemacht haben machen jetzt gerade
die steine rausrechnen das antun nach
ein bisschen an gießen ein bisschen
abwarten kurz an feuchten wenn man
gefeuert haben legen wir den rollrasen
drauf das geht richtig so schnell und
muss sagen das macht richtig spaß jetzt
ein bisschen an reichen das heißt wir
tun die steil noch raus und zwar hier
steine unter dem rasen muss nicht sein
und es wichtig beim rollrasen ist
natürlich ist aller aller wichtigste
der untergrund muss stimmen richtig
jungs richtig
der untergrund bestimmen er muss schön
plan eben sein darf keine dellen haben
muss gut befestigt sein und das sind die
wichtigen sachen die nur wissen muss bei
einem rollrasen legen 200 quadratmeter
rollrasen legen wir zusammen und dann
legen wir los ich mache auch machst du
das heißt der rabatt nur und macht
nichts
die gute vorbereitung ist eines bodens
ist es a und o eines rollrasen links
wenn du das schon richtig gemacht hast
dann willst du später gar keine probleme
haben und es ist dann nachher einfach so
wie er als mit schönen laminatboden
legen nur noch viel schneller viel
cooler und du brauchst auch kaum
werkzeuge dazu bis auf dem messer ein
langes messer haben wir es dabei felix
haben wir dabei brauche nur solange es
wie so ein döner messer und dadurch
schneidet durch den rasen durch und
verlegen ist richtig cool
das macht richtig spaß einige macht
alles spaß was man immer sofort zieht
der vorteil bei einem rollrasen
natürlich auch wenn jetzt wie gesagt an
normalen rasen sehen tut da kommt
meistens die vögel und die kölner die
auf den boden werfen
das saatgut fressen die können ja schon
weg dann habt ihr überall so kahle
stellen oder andere vorteile ich bin ja
so ein rollrasen nimmt dann müsst ihr
zum beispiel erst alle drei jahre
ungefähr vertikutieren dh den rasen
durchlüften die ganzen abgestorbene
pflanzenteile rausnehmen das macht ja
dann alle drei jahre den rasen selber
seht dann machte das gleich jedes jahr
schon alle zwei jahre am anfang ist
gleich ein rollrasen ein tick teurer
aber im endeffekt hatten wirklich
weniger arbeit damit und wie gesagt das
genial ist beim rollrasen es ist sofort
grün und es sind jetzt gleich so manchen
rollrasen abholen gehen jetzt ins
gemacht okay was drauf ich zeige mir wie
so ein rollrasen geerntet wird kommt er
mal kurz mit und sowie der geändert wird
so machten es auch wenn ihr schon
bestehenden rasen habt ihr möchten
rollrasen reinlegen und mit den
bestehenden rasen raus haben wollt dann
müsst ihr auch sony sony nennt sich das
band eine fräse ja wenn ihr schon
bestehenden rasen habt dann müsst ihr
euch einfach bei seinen baumaschinen
ferner haben wir ja auch so eine schöne
maschine holen und mit dieser chemischen
maschine macht ihr euch die obersten
aber wie sagt man dazu die obersten
arbeit von von vom gras weg und habt ihr
auch nachher sohn boden und wieso also
eine maschine aussieht mit dem ernten
sie nämlich auch den ganzen rasen da
gehen wir jetzt hin also jungs kommen
gehen
so jetzt sind wir in reilingen uns in
reilingen hole ich unseren rasen und der
rasen der wird hier geerntet hört sich
lustig an der person traktor um und
erntet die oberfläche also die sonde
steitz genau oben an der obergrenze ab
und alle tiere mit den rasen und genau
diesen rasen werde ich nachher bei uns
im garten wieder verbaut
[Musik]
nachdem mit dem boden gerächt haben und
gerade gezogen haben gegen mit der walze
noch einmal drüber
das sieht jetzt aus wie fred feuerstein
die wahrheit ist auch wirklich so so
bekommt ihr zum beispiel im baumarkt
könnt ihr euch ausleihen
die müsste er sich extra kaufen das ist
einfach so so wie gesagt so ne metall
walze wo man mit wasser füllen tut und
die kammer hinter sich herziehen die
kann man im baumarkt leyen ich glaube
zwischen fünf und zehn euro kostet pro
tag ich keine große investition dh
eigentlich ist beim beim rasen verlegen
will ich nur so ihr müsst nur noch den
dünger kaufen ist auch kein großes geld
kommt noch die größe natürlich an wie
groß oder rasendünger kaufen ihr braucht
messer
da könnt ihr langes brotmesser nehmen
und dann hat auch die walz und der rasen
an sich
[Musik]
so jetzt ist der rollrasen ja schon
gekommen und hier sieht man auch wenn
man ganz genau darauf drauf schaut die
die rasen wurzeln wurden hier gezählt
also würden sie wirklich abgetrennt und
damit die rasen wurzeln sofort an den
boden anwachsen
zum letzten starter dünger drauf machen
das nimmt man auch so ins theater dünger
bisschen wo sind die eigentlich hier
sind sie genau bevor man den rollrasen
es liegt schon ein bisschen starter
drauf bisschen verteilen und immer so
und natürlich handschuhe benutzen jetzt
noch ein bisschen feucht machen bevor
man den rasen legt weil der rasen schon
ziemlich trocken gekommen ist damit
jetzt einfach angesetzt muss man muss
man immer schauen dass man nicht stoß
anstoß also hier seitlich stoß
einspruchs macht schon immer ein versatz
das ding legt schön an die kante ran an
die rasenkante heran
ein bisschen vorziehen idealerweise legt
man sich immer eine schalttafel hin
dann hat man nachher diese knie abdrücke
nicht und ihr seht mal wie schnell das
geht mit den jungs so schön andrücken
und ihr seht ich habe hier ein ganz
normales tomatenmesser mit diesem ganz
normales tomatenmesser das hat jeder von
euch zu hause in der küche
idealerweise wäre es noch ein bisschen
länger ist aber kein problem
und jetzt mal einfach an erkrankte in
lang schneiden das kinderstück nehmen
und vor mir grad an und hier vorne
wieder anfriert
hier können wir mit dem nächsten stoß
rangehen und wir überlegen
ich sehe es geht ratzfatz rasen legen
und das macht auch richtig spaß und ganz
wichtig ist es immer im versatz legen
das heißt nicht hier schauen dass du
immer ein stück legten dann hier
weitermache schon wirklich im versatz
dass es hier zuwächse perfekt zusammen
und nächste
[Musik]
okay zwei okay das kann natürlich auch
passiert ich mir auch schon passiert
dass das messer oder blasen vergisst
oder den hamster kann auch passieren
[Musik]
und jeder landschaftsgärtner der nachher
im garten gestaltet so wie jetzt ich
unser felix felix und ich ist es am
schönsten ist sozusagen die kür am
schluss den rollrasen zulegen und die
besitzer sehen nachher einfach ball war
sofort grün und so ein rollrasen ich
kann ich nur empfehlen das ist viel
besser als 1 zu sehen
und der kommt auch bei uns aus der
region der kommt aus rheinstetten habe
ich rechts felix rheinhausen china
rheinhausen man sich alles rein und ich
hab mir eingelegt und sich danach heraus
nach erfahrungen mit der walze einmal
drüber sind noch ein bisschen zu
festigen und dann wird in den nächsten
zwei wochen richtig schön gegossen und
erst nach zwei wochen darf dann unser
mähroboter hinten da war dann auf die
piste die station installiert gestern
und nämlich mal gespannt wie es nachher
alles wirkt das ganze smartphone system
das die bewässerung des wird nachher
auch smart komplett bewässert die
bewässerungsanlage habe ich ja schon
eingelegt sagte er schon video gesehen
ja und dann haben wir unseren garten
fertig einen tollen garten mit so wenig
arbeit benötigt und zwar nur die sachen
zu machen die einen spaß machen darf
so jetzt habe ich die wahl c mit wasser
gefüllt und jetzt werde ich dem den
rasen jetzt noch einmal platt walzen
damit diese in stücke noch
zusammenkleben und eines heißen einmal
links einmal quer fahren jetzt übrigen
kompletten rasen drüber wenn ich das
gemacht habe dann werde ich das erste
mal in meinem leben ich hab ich gestern
schon gemacht
zweimal meinem leben den rasensprenger
anschalten und den rasen bewässern so
dass man ungefähr zwei wochen lang immer
morgens mittags je nach bedarf es kommt
darauf an wie trockenes wird und dann
darf auf diesen rasen zwei wochen lang
keine mails drauf und erst in zwei
wochen werde ich dann den rasenmäher
starten und zwar hier
meine frau hat gesagt er hat frieda oder
sie heißt frieda und damit frieda
starten und das stinkt nach dem hin
ja also jetzt fahre ich immer die big
red feuerstein hierüber jungs ich mach
das
ihr habt ja schon mal gemacht ich habe
studiert reise westhoff paris
[Musik]
jetzt heißt dann auch gleich immer
wässern wässern wässern so dass der
rasen richtig cool anwächst
ich war jetzt einmal komplett hoch und
dann seitlich
[Musik]
so jetzt ist der rasen drin ich habe
jetzt auch schon bewässert und der muss
jetzt alle und jeden tag so kommt auf
später natürlich darauf an so zwei-
dreimal bewässert werden am besten
morgens und abends nicht in der prallen
sonne ganz ganz wichtig jetzt wächst der
rasen langsam an
und jetzt darf auch zwei drei wochen
lang nicht betreten werden
das ist ganz ganz wichtig deswegen haben
wir jetzt mal ein bisschen abgesperrt
der muss richtig schön anwachsen und
auch in zwei drei wochen werde ich auch
erst mal den rasenmäher laufen lassen
wir haben den freuen uns riesig drauf
und wie gesagt zwei wochen jetzt einfach
mal ruhen lassen und mal schauen was
passiert wenn man rollrasen pflanzt da
gibt es so was wie eine bauernregel und
man sagt man sagt eigentlich einen
rollrasen pflanzt man am besten in den
monaten die monitore haben das heißt mai
juni juli das in einer idealen monate
den rasen zu pflanzen
ansonsten ich habe muss ich sage ich
habe auch schon mal eine im dezember
gepflanzt da hatten wir aber 18 grad und
geniale ihr seht auch schon genial was
in so kurzer zeit passieren kann und wie
schnell so ein garten auf seiner
baustelle zu den richtig coolen garten
wird ja und jetzt waren wir zwei drei
wochen und dann wird sally frieda
anschließen und frieda wird hier laufen
und alles abnehmen automatisch da freuen
uns riesig drauf mal nachgesehen meister
und dreisprung 72 montreal münchen oder
montreal so blasig angewachsen ist ein
sechs wochen vergangen und den sechs
wochen ist dass ich viel passiert wenn
ihr noch ein bisschen rum schaut wenn
die anfingen gesehen wir vorgelegt haben
und was denn alles geblüht hat und was
man im garten schon verändert haben wir
am anfang nicht so viel wässert dann
müssen sich die wurzel möglich dass
wasser aus der tiefe holen die die
wurzeln richtig lang und der rasen mit
richtig fest wie gesagt dann ist es ganz
wichtig am anfang nicht viel zu wässern
nicht zu übertreiben aber auch nicht zu
wenig das ist so ein ding name ist ein
gewisses ausmaß haben übertreibt es
einfach nicht der rasen ist alles
angewachsen wie hammermäßig der aussieht
und das würdest du mit einem gesäten
rasen würde ich nicht so schnell
hinbekommen und ich muss auch ehrlich
sagen auch nicht so schön
ich habe jetzt meinen job gemacht
ich habe den rasen gepflanzt gesät gesät
habe ich nicht gelegt und der rest macht
jetzt unsere frieda wir haben im namen
frieda gegeben weil frieda ist sowieso
ein sinnbild für mich jemand fleißiges
jemand der nie aufgibt und der tag und
nacht beschäftigt ist und unsere frieda
macht ist und was die frieda genau macht
das erklärte jetzt meine frau stellen
jetzt gucken wir mal was frieda macht
friede hat mittlerweile ein dach über
dem kopf so ist ja auch vor der sonne
geschützt und wird nicht regelmäßig nach
friede friede hatte ich ja gar nicht da
die fleißige macht die arbeitet immer
dies bestimmt irgendwo dahinten im
garten ist immer schwierig denn man hört
sie nicht da ich säße blau
da ist die frieda frieda ist jetzt auch
schon seit über vier wochen ja vier
wochen im einsatz der rasen liegt jetzt
schon eine weile und ich muss echt sagen
der rasen ist wunderschön
meine freundin die hat auch gerade einen
rasen gemacht aber termin gesät und der
liegt jetzt glaube ich schon seit drei
wochen und es wächst natürlich sehr
langsam nicht so dicht wie bei uns und
ich habe gleich gesagt mach deinen
rollrasen so ist sein buch hat bei uns
macht frieda ist bei uns wirklich sehr
fleißig ist jeden tag im einsatz
und jetzt haben wir die möglichkeit wir
mussten jetzt natürlich erst einmal
schauen wie arbeitet sie wie schneidet
sie und ich habe ganz schnell
festgestellt frieda fährt nicht die
schlangenlinie hoch und wieder runter
also so regelmäßig sitzt vielleicht
gemacht hatte frieda fährt zickzack über
den rasen und wählt sich einfach den
kürzesten weg und bisher wirklich sehr
effektiv und sehr effizient der rasen
ist immer wunderschön gemäht und wie
gesagt am anfang schon die vorteile sind
einfach ich muss keinen rasen mähen
murat muss es nicht mehr machen
der rasen wird gemäht wenn wir zum
beispiel mal weg sind oder im urlaub
sind er ist immer auf den millimeter
genau gekürzt und vor allem hat man
einen natürlichen dünger
weil der rasen wirklich ganz kurz
abgeschnitten wird und dieser rasen
abfall den man ebenfalls auch nicht
entsorgen muss einfach direkt wieder als
dünger auf den rasen fällt und somit
wieder rasen immer dichter es entsteht
kein unkraut und auch kein muss also hat
man wirklich immer ein wunderschönes
ergebnis kommt gehen wir mal zusammen
zufrieden
die fährt dann nämlich und guckt mal
gefährdet da zur kante hin und da haben
wir den draht zehn zentimeter vom rand
entfernt angebracht die zweite sondern
leicht drüber und wieder zurück und hat
jetzt praktisch
die rasenkante schön abgemäht bei
größeren sachen wie zum beispiel beim
oliv baum haben wir 35 cm abstand
gelassen damit sie eben nicht
da kommt jetzt durch damit sie eben
nicht an die steine dran fährt aber
gerade hier aber gerade jetzt an dem
beet da fährt sie wieder bis zur kante
mehr die kante noch schön weg und fährt
dann wieder zurück und am anfang haben
wir frieda manuell bedient mittlerweile
haben wir sie jetzt programmiert sie
fährt bei uns immer vormittags denn
nachts ist zwar eigentlich auch ganz
logisch weil nachts eben auch keiner auf
der wiese ist aber nach sind ganz viele
tiere nachtaktiv und deswegen haben wir
kommen aus tierschutzgründen lassen wir
sie nicht nachts laufen da können igel
nämlich auf die wiese kommen vögel
frösche kröten oder auch andere tiere
und ich will die tiere einfach nicht
verletzen
daher läuft sie bei uns vormittags da
sind die kinder aus dem haus sind in der
schule im kindergarten
wir sind drinnen ich drehe in der küche
im rat arbeitet in der werkstatt oder
auch woanders und deswegen ist bei uns
eigentlich vormittags immer am besten
was ich mich auch direkt gefragt habe
ich meine wir mit unseren garten
angelegt ich habe diese drähte verlegt
und was passiert wenn ich jetzt einen
gegenstand dazu hole was passiert wenn
plötzlich was im weg liegt wenn die
kinder was stehen lassen das zeigen wir
euch mal was stellst du dich mal gleich
in den weg dann können wir mal zeigen
was passiert wenn frieda einen
gegenstand mitten auf der straße hat
also auf der wiese hier warten kurz bist
du nicht der ecke fertig ist jetzt bitte
nicht nachmachen wir zeigen euch einmal
kurz als auch sie hält an und fährt
einfach zurück fährt am hindernis
sozusagen vorbei du provozierst du jetzt
aber haben da kommt jetzt gleich seine
so eine sprechblase provoziere mich
nicht zum glück ist unsere frieda nicht
aggressiv
aber ich mache sie mal kurz weg machen
kürzeste murat machte elop
und wenn man jetzt zum beispiel einen
großen gegenstand noch platziert wie zum
beispiel eine sonnenliege oder nochmal
kübel mit einer großen pflanze
da muss krida natürlich nicht ständig
dagegen rennen dann nimmt man dann
einfach noch mal diesen draht und den
kann man ja auch oberflächlich eben
platzieren anstecken und dann eben noch
mal da hinten verbinden und fertig da
hat man das problem nicht ja und ich
sehe jetzt auch frieda ist ein bisschen
schmutzig ist aber gar nicht schlimm
entweder wird sie vom regen sauber
gewaschen oder vom murat eine kleine
abkühlung
diese regenbogen fotokarten regenbogen
und nicht mich nach waren und wir haben
einfach die app bei murat auf dem handy
installiert das heißt morath kann da
immer mal schauen ob alles in ordnung
ist wir sind jetzt bald im urlaub und
frieda wird trotzdem weiter fleißig
arbeiten falls doch ein problem
auftreten sollte sehen wie es auf dem
handy da kriegen wir eine
benachrichtigung und dann kann man
einfach danach schauen und herren
olivenbaum haben wir ja diese 35
zentimeter abstand gelassen
man sieht es auch hier ganz gut diese
rasenkante wird nicht mit gemäht die
kann man jetzt entweder mit einer
gartenschere einfach wegschneiden also
nacharbeiten wir lassen uns einfach so
ich finde es auch schön und natürlich
aus passt zu unserem garten denn wir
wollen auch kein garten der omega
perfekt aussieht hier spielen die kinder
wissen hier ständig von schönen
naturgarten aber eben trotzdem gepflegt
das war also die vorstellung unseres
neuen familienmitglieds frieda die
arbeitet jetzt fleißig bei uns ist bei
uns herzlich willkommen und werden sie
schon sendung zu herz geschlossen
was man natürlich fairerweise dazusagen
muss im rasen roboter hat natürlich
höhere anschaffungskosten als ein
herkömmlicher rasenmäher
aber uns war es das wirklich wert denn
ich habe keinen schnitt abfall den ich
weg bringen muss jeden tag ist der rasen
gemäht und ich habe einfach ganz viel
zeit für andere schöne dinge im garten
von daher und außerdem ist die frieda
mega anständig frieda findet nämlich
immer von ganz alleine den weg wieder
nach hause
[Musik]